in letzter Minute konnte er aus dem Iran
fliehen und lebt jetzt in Deutschland
erfahren 24 Jahre alt iranische
Sicherheitskräfte sind ihm auf den
Fersen November 2022 erfahren
protestiert in seiner Heimatstadt
Wanderer Boss gegen das Regime
dann fallen Schüsse
erfahren wird gezielt auf die Augen
geschossen mit Schrotkugeln bis heute
lebt der mit Schmerzen erzählt er uns
wurde von 25 rotkugeln getroffen sieben
stecken davon noch in meinem Körper in
meinem rechten Auge in meinem Kiefer in
der Hand in der Brust und im Hals
Bilder unmittelbar nach dem Anschlag
erfahren wird notdürftig privat versorgt
die revolutionsgarten haben
Krankenhäusern jegliche Hilfsdienste
untersagt immer noch steckt eine Kugel
in seinem rechten Auge erklärt er von
seinem Betreuer von den Malteser in
Mainz wenn man die Kugel heraus operiert
wurde zu erblinden sagte
erfahren ist kann Einzelfall auch Milad
hat den Karat spartieran demonstriert
auch ihn wurde in die Augen geschossen
gerade noch meine Hand heben von den
sieben Schrotkugeln trafen viele meiner
Hand und meinen Körper nur wenige mein
Auge sonst wäre es ganz geplatzt blind
zu werden erzeugt große Angst das Regime
will die Menschen einschüchtern
auch deswegen sind die Proteste abgeerbt
die Menschen suchen inzwischen andere
Formen des Protestes und das Regime
schürt weiter Angst erst am Freitag
wurden drei Männer hingerichtet unter
Folter geben sie zu diese
Sicherheitskräfte getötet zu haben
nachprüfen können wir das nicht
es gibt seit vielen Wochen bereits eine
exekutionswelle in der Islamischen
Republik laut UN wurden mindestens 200
Menschen bereits hingerichtet die
Dunkelziffer ist wohl viel höher das
Regime versucht nicht nur abzuschrecken
sondern auch zu bestrafen all jene die
gegen die islamische Republik auf die
Straße gegangen sind auch dem in den
Iran entführten Deutsch iranischen
Staatsbürger und Regimekritiker macht
droht die Hinrichtung seine Tochter
fordert erneut Hilfe von der
Bundesregierung
in Geiselnahme beschäftigt der sich mit
den Europäern beschäftigt der sich damit
beschäftigt was warum das Massen
Hinrichtung ist der sich mit Druck
einsetzt um diesen Regime zu zeigen dass
es unsere rote Linie ihr könnt nicht so
weitermachen
Milad sind durch ihre Flucht eine
möglichen Todesstrafe zuvorgekommen
jetzt haben sie politisches Asyl
beantragt doch langfristig wollen sie
zurück
weil sie mich in Iran verhaften und
umbringen wollten ich war gezwungen
hierherzukommen mein Ziel ist es den
Iran zu befreien ich will die Stimme
meines Volkes sein damit unsere
Revolution erfolgreich wird wenn der
Iran befreit ist werde ich auf jeden
Fall in meine Heimat zurückkehren
zwei Regime-Gegner die ihr Leben
riskiert haben und die wollen dass das
Schicksal der Menschen in Iran nicht in
Vergessenheit gerät